but in my heart Brooklyn nine-nine has a
special place so first of all
congratulations on your marriage like
it's like everyone's together on it yes
so listen I'm very happy but there was a
moment there where we thought this was
the end of an era and then you got saved
so tell me about that what went down we
were let go as a show by the Fox Network
yeah our hearts were broken then
seemingly in the 11th hour and an
upswell social media support sure yes
and when I say the 11th hour I mean like
11 hours later NBC decided to pick up
the show and give us the season 6
rejoicing was abundant because when I
first heard that you were cancelled I
thought oh Andy's asked for it to be
cancelled because he's ready to move on
to something else that was my is that
okay I just love that that was what she
thought to be really quiet and I was
just like oh no like he's ready the cast
is like they're gonna he's gonna go
through something else now but you
didn't want it to be canceled you were I
love that you think I have so many great
options okay and so you know when when
Fox decided not to renew you were you
all like oh miss you guys like what yeah
and then almost instantly you were
picked up so you're like I miss you
we're like a full night of being
devastated it was a terrible night it
was really like a 23 hour cycle yeah
holy crap I can't believe that just
happened and then you know Dan Gore and
Dave miner and make sure yeah and myself
a little we're all sort of talking
throughout the whole day being like
where else can we take it is there a
chance that could have a second life
yeah
and it was looking pretty dire you know
amongst the cast and people who were
watching the show talking about each
other and like it definitely felt like
the end yeah yeah but I think that
helped convince NBC to pick up the show
in a way to see the outpouring of love
for the show and what does it mean to
you know to they'll have those fans
you're also critically acclaimed and
then to have the executives also be like
hey there's still life here it was it
was wonderful just to get that support
first of all and then you think that you
know you're you're five years are over
and this family that you've kind of
created it's done and then suddenly you
get like resuscitated I think Andy said
it's really fun it's like being like
watching everyone come to your funeral
or like okay so now you're on NBC what's
going to change the bug in the corner
yes yeah same shenanigans like do we
have to change any characters anyone
getting cut Andy nothing like that
[Laughter]
didn't work out for him poor guy I do
know from experience of working at NBC
that we're allowed to do bleeps and
blurs now okay and I don't know if we're
going to seize that opportunity yeah I
hope so are you guys voting yesterday
yeah well they go on a curse like
Brigade but like he doesn't get it right
he just can't say curse words right we I
think are allowed to say the names of
different products that we were allowed
to do at Fox
[Music]
don't wait to see all those products
like referencing them by writing smacked
with a Swiffer you nobody's room for
jokes we've gotten passage so many so
many like I don't know sister like a
brown got an Emmy nomination I guess
starring on the couch is so exciting I
feel like sterling K Brown gets Emmy
nominated just like walk down the street
you're like wow sterling got amazing why
is he so deserving of this nomination
he's just a magnetic dude ya know I was
just gonna say that episode was amazing
and incredible and like totally out out
of the box for what we usually do on the
show and I thought they pulled it off so
well and it was and I was thinking like
oh it must be so crazy to be like hey
come be a guest on our show and it's
gonna be you for the entire episode and
Andy and Andre and just like sterling
just came in and jumped right in with
everybody and I thought that said he's
not so super magnetic nice guy
I can't before I've met him before he
came on the show and he's just such a
big personality and he kind of listens
to you and he just he's a really nice
guy to be no one ever listens listen to
me
[Music]
okay so now you're an NBC pretty big
powerful Network who's on the bucket
list in terms of what well to get as
guest stars now people know they can get
Emmy nominations on your show it's about
something be flock of Brooklyn nine-nine
well we have the obvious one that I
think they've been trying to get for a
while which is mr. Willis obsessed with
die hard okay so do you want to like we
see Bruce all the time do you want to
give a plea like we'll pass it along
I think you should finish it up it yeah
okay
Hey Bruce look my character Jake Peralta
on the show Brooklyn nine-nine which is
moderately successful is obsessed with
die hard and he thinks your character
John McClane is the coolest character
maybe in the history of cinema hi Andy
Samberg I'm a comedian also feel that
way if you'd come be on the show even if
it's for like one sentence just like a
cool cameo like we bump into each other
on the street you go excuse me and then
walk away
that was a bad impression don't take
that personally don't make your decision
based off that impression of the one
sentence thing I was pitching if you had
it in your schedule to just breeze by
just for one shot I think it'd mean a
lot real quick to the show to the fan
base to fans of diehard who have picked
up on how much the show loves the movie
that's my pitch I mean I thought it was
really good and also you know listen we
film Entertainment Tonight and Brooklyn
nine-nine on the CBS Radford lot which
has excellent iced tea at Carla's cafe
so I'm just letting you know that to
persuade us okay the next trouble place
date we've had it okay
so between this how's life as a daddy Oh
for me yeah it's wonderful are you so
busy are you like we like oh no I almost
lost my job how will I support my child
according to you I would have been
totally fine yeah it's it's a busy life
I feel very fortunate that my hours in
every day are all full yeah but I loved
every second of it are you feeling a
little bit guilty for you as a child
because I know that creatives like we
tend to be like how when we're kids so
now are you like damn it was hard to be
a parent
oh because I was such a spaz yeah can I
feel bad for my parents yeah yeah have
you had like that full circle where
you're like wow it was hard I've
definitely had that conversation with my
parents forever wow I must have been a
real pain in the ass like there's gonna
be a butt and then they just so many
Brooklyn babies is there a chance that
there's like a Brooklyn babies daycare
and like why are we not live-streaming
maybe NBC could degrees there's
certainly Brooklyn baby playdates okay
who hosts the best playdate I've been
supposed to host one for about four
months now and it hasn't happened I mean
I didn't want to say it's fast
approaching it's fast approaching we're
doing a little yardwork but it's almost
done okay
so between these two gentlemen sitting
here if you had to you know nominate one
of them to be your babysitter moving
forward like who would you trust you're
putting me in a terrible position so you
gotta say Jess I do have to say Jojo
knows my kid did you fail amazing we'll
listen congratulations I'm so excited
that we are around for more and that's
it and I'm just gonna also mention since
we're live and everyone can see it I'm
ready for my cameo you know right beside
you like I could just walk walk across
the log I think it's been doing the news
in the background I could report it
could be in the whole things
what do you look like a big jug of
moonshine you could be here viewing
Bruce Willis on the street okay now I
will get on the Bruce Willis Trainor
making this happen yes call my people
brawls all those again on you Bruce okay
come over here last thing this is our
really fun little booth as you can see
like all the cash